وكاله الجزيره قد حصلت على صور للمراه
المنتبهي في تنفيذها تفجير اسطنبول وتظهر
فرارها بين جموع من الناس قبل وقوع
الانفجار بلحظات وتواصلها عبر هاتف نقال
معنا من شارع الاستقلال في اسطنبول
الحاج واضحه عمر انك في موقع
الهجوم صف لنا ما يجري وايضا ردود الفعل
حول المعلومات التي اعلنت عنها السلطات
الامنيه بخصوص
الهجوم والاشخاص الذين تم توقفهام
نعم عبد الصمد نبدا بالمعلومات التي باتت
تتكشف اكثر فاكثر على حول ما جرى يوم امس
وكيف تمت عمليه القاء القبض على المشتبهي
فيها في وضع حقيبه حقيبه متفجرات السلطات
التركيه اعلن في بيان لها قبل قليل انها
القت القبض عليها عند الساعه الثالثه
بالتوقيت المحلي الثالثه فجرا بعد
مراجعتها اكثر من الف ومئتين ساعه
لكاميرات المراقبه المنتشره في هذه
المنطقه وشرحت كيفيه تناقلها من موقع
الهجوم الى مكان المكان اللي القي فيه
القبض عليها قالت انها وضعت الحقيبه وبقيت
لاربعه لاكثر من 40 دقيقه وغادرت قبل
لحظات متوجهه باتجاه الميداني تقسيم بعد
ذلك استقلت سياره اخذتها الى احد الاحياء
هو حي السنار البعيد نسبيا عن مركز
المدينه ثم بعد ذلك انطلق انتقلت الى حي
اخر سلطات تركيا بدات همم عملياتها عقبه
الانفجار مباشره وقد انها القت القبضه
بدايه على سته واربع شخصا مشتبه بتعاونهم
مع هذه همم المنافذه او الشخص الذي ترك
حقيبه متفجرات وقالوا انهم هم الذين
ابلغوا بمكان وجودها انها كان في ذلك
انتقلت الى كتب حي الاخر حينها القي القبض
عليها لكن هناك تفاصيل مثيره في هذه
القضيه وزير الداخليه قال ان هناك
مخطط لتنفيذ عمليات اخرى في مناطق اخرى في
اسطنبول وايضا في مناطق اخرى من تركيا 21
من هؤلاء كان المنوط بهم التنفيذ عمليات
في مناطق مختلفه من في تركيا وفي اسطنبول
كذلك الامر اشار الى التدريبات التي
تلقتها هذه المنفذه قالت انها تلقت
التدريبات على ان تكون عنصرا للاستخبارات
الخاصه بوحداث حمايه الشعب وهي منظمه
تصنفها تركيا انها منظمه الارهابيه تابعه
لحزب العمال الكردستاني المصنف الارهابيا
اكثر من 40 عاما قالت انها دخلت الى تركيا
مناطق تسيطر عليها فصائل همم الجيش السوري
الحر اضافه الى انها انتقلت الى مدينه
اسطنبول قبل وقت وجيز وكان ايضا من
المفترض ان تنتقل الى اليونان تحدثت ايضا
ان عن تفصيل يشير الى ان هناك شخصا انيط
به التخلص منها وقتلها بعد تنفيذها
للعمليه ولكن السلطات تركيه عبر اعتراض
كثير من المكالمات ومره اخرى مراجعه
الكثير من معلومات تمكن من القاء القبض
على هذا الشخص ولا نعرف حتى الان ان كان
هناك تفاصيل اخرى عن مناطق التي كانت
ستستهدف ربما من قبل هؤلاء ال 21 ال 21
مشتبهان بالمناسبه السلطات تركيه لم تقفل
التحقيقات حتى الان تقول للتحقيقات مستمره
ربما هناك دلائل اخرى او همم ربما مخططات
اخرى قد تكون هؤلاء لما تكشف السلطات
الرسميه عنها بعد النقاب ولكن يبدو اننا
امام ازمه حقيقيه دبلوماسيه بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وايضا تركيا اسير
الداخليه سليمان سولو في حديثه امس واليوم
وجهه انتقادا عند الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وقال انها راعيه لمنظمات
الارهابيه تقتل مدنيين في تركيا وايضا في
سوريا وانه قال ان الحكومه التركيه لا
تقبل ابدا عزاء الذي قدم من السفاره
الامريكيه هنا في تركيا ذلك انها هي من
ترعى هذه المنظمات الارهابيه يعني
التفاعلات هنا على المستوى الدي الشعبي
كما تشاهدون خلف هذه المكان بالتحديد سقطت
فيه قتلت فيه طفله ووالدها عمرها خمس
سنوات
سته الجنسيات هم كلهم من المواطنين
الاتراك هذا المكان تحول كما ترون الى
مزار همم قبل قليل شاهدنا اسود الكثير من
الممثلين الاحزاب السياسيه التركيه
المختلفه توجهات الى هنا تقديم العزاء كما
قالوا لي الشعب التركي اخيرا حصلت الجرح
خمسه في حاله خطر والعدد همم
اشكرك
من شارع الاستقلال في اسطنبول